these walls have seen decades of
bloodshed
I've come to Belfast in Northern Ireland
and booked a tour of the so called peace
walls my driver Peter grew up in the
shadow of these structures that are
designed to keep Catholics and
Protestants segregated so he knows his
way around they say because they are a
temporary structure that they didn't mop
them but is 46 years old you pull up
your Google Maps today and look we're
standing at the wall there is no wall
there because it doesn't exist
but for many in Belfast the walls are a
sad reality tena Patrick who lives in a
Protestant neighborhood tells me it is
still too early to bring the walls down
the gate she lives right next to his
only open during the day and there are
good reasons for that the last murder
that was done here was done on a bicycle
or a cycle a motorbike
so that's on people's minds as well
there's a lot of lot of work needs to be
done on the minds of people rather than
the physical thing itself almost 20
years after the Good Friday peace
agreement between Catholic nationalists
and Protestant unionists she still gets
stones and bottles thrown at her house
she was involved in the petition to get
what is today Belfast's longest peace
wall I fail at the wall hard enough one
top our community would have suffered a
domino effects as Isis were wracked and
burnt so the wall then was erected Nazi
after our community it was more it was
like a it was like a barrier of strength
around our community the concept proved
so popular for both Protestant and
Catholic communities alike that the
number of permanent walls actually
increased after the peace agreement in
1998 but my cab driver Peter a Catholic
tells me they're still hope at a
memorial site for fighters of the IRA
terror group he explains that some
residents pour down the cages protecting
their backyard
to see Lane on the wall for the existent
14 weeks ago they took a day for Aggie
and that's the perception of your
normality and my normality my normality
was this Kia's and fences and protection
your normality is where they fought so
for me these two hoods are taking them
turned is a big step forward a big big
step for me so that's the kind of
progress we left the progress were
looking at by these standards events on
Crumlin wrote my next stop are something
akin to a revolution this is where the
first piece wall fell to be replaced by
railings I continued my kept tour our
next stop is a divided Park in north
Belfast
it now has a passage connecting both
sides a new gate opened a few metal
grills gone a wall down but 98 walls to
go Belfast is living proof of how
difficult it is to overcome the
invisible dividing lines on the
Protestant side of the fence the
community worker who helped bring down
the first wall in Belfast is Ian
McLaughlin he believes the remaining
walls will only come down if there is
the prospect of a better life for local
people the Good Friday Agreement
promised jobs investment and a better
future for for this society in many
cases that promise has yet to be
fulfilled so we still have areas of
multiple deprivation high poverty levels
and those areas today
replicate the areas in which they were
worst parts of the conflict took place
in this country
cap driver Peter says the Berlin Wall
moment is still a distant dream for
Belfast in the meantime the city can at
least profit from the tourists coming to
visit the walls